Bob let's say I'm a beginning
screenwriter where would I began to
research film history so I could broaden
my perspective of storytelling I think
wonderful place to begin as at the
beginning and look at the entire history
of movies because the situation at the
beginning was kind of like we are right
now when movies began nobody knew with
his business whatever turn into and no
one really knew how to tell the story
and so they wind it and you had the
Lumiere brothers sending guys out onto
the street with tripods and cameras and
making 47 movies and at Georgia madea's
you know concocting little fantasies in
the studio and in their own primitive
way they were attempting to figure out
how to tell stories in film and so I
personally think that's the greatest
place to be in at all it's simple it's
easy and it's clear because the
challenge is and making movies are
always the same no matter what kind of
material what kind of equipment you're
using you always want to attempt to find
some kind of sympathetic character and
be a struggle and there's going to be
the three acts and that stuff doesn't
ever go away and I think I find that
when you begin to look at some of the
movies from the past you begin to get
some perspective on who you are and the
kind of story you want to tell and what
it owes to some of the world in the past
I guess whats Alan wants that the Zen
philosopher who said something about the
ocean and the fish and everybody knows
it but I'll repeat it anyway which is I
don't know who it was who discovered the
ocean but it certainly wasn't the fish
and we are fish in our own little ocean
here and I think it helps to get out of
that little contemporary ocean a little
bit and to look at other possibilities
other times when filmmakers were
attempting to
all stories in movies or make
documentaries and movies because then it
gives your level of freedom but you
don't have otherwise once you're outside
of it once you can step out of side your
little moment in time and your world you
then have a kind of choice you can say I
love it it's fantastic I want to get
right back into it or else you can say
I'm out of there I see it a different
way and I want to tell stories
differently I want to be different kind
of filmmaker I want to be a different
kind of person so my answer is start at
the beginning and work your way through
that's really what my book is all about
so with the beginning those were the
talkies right is that no I won't know
back I want to go away before the
talkies I wanted of the silence the
silence yeah I want to go to sorry i
meant a dream it I want to go back to
sort of judgment years prancing around
this little studio in Paris I'm making
those imaginary kind of movies that
Martin Scorsese sort of looked back on
with fondness and you go um you know um
what year was this sorry what what year
was though it were silent film well sir
first sound film was eighteen
ninety-five and 1895 couple of
filmmakers the lumiere brothers who were
the sons of a prominent French film
company kind of like Kodak hit on a way
to use a small camera to shoot film to
develop it and to project it equal to
the cinematograph and in 1895 they
rented some space in a cafe in Paris and
exhibited it to train coming up people
walk in a factory some kids beside the
lake and people were a god because
they'd never seen anything like that one
of the first people who sat in on the
movie was a magician named George
madea's sustained magician p saw the
film and said my god what a fantastic a
that would be for storytelling in movies
for making magic I mean particularly
sort of figured that when he got himself
a camera went out on the street and in
the middle of shooting the camera jammed
he then reloaded his shot again and
suddenly what had been a bus turned into
magically a hearse and suddenly said oh
my goodness here is a new world here's a
new way to tell stories and I can do it
with this picture stuff so I'm saying
yeah that going all the way back is a
great place to begin what were the fears
at that time I'm sure there were
definitely all the the pros of people
thinking oh new ways to tell stories but
i imagining their people were very
fearful of this new method well there
were the first show for example it is
said who knows if this is true but it is
claimed that when they first saw this
train arriving a little suburban station
in the South of France nacio tah is the
name of the city people saw the train
coming at them only 10 because they're
afraid the trainer's came right off the
screen it's unbelievable to us but there
was that level of reaction the other
kind of fear was that from the producers
point of view this whole thing would
last Lumiere brothers oh really in large
part with Edison and others invented the
business got out of it real quick
because their fear was it was incredible
money drain that nothing whatever
happened to the stuff that there was no
future in movies and they wouldn't even
sell a Cameron anybody because was
pointless it was just a little demo that
they ran and it wouldn't go anywhere so
there were those kinds of certainly
those kinds of fears so let's say
someone's 25 right now and they say you
know what I know exactly the type of
film I want to make and I can do it
myself and I can shoot it for cheap why
should I learn about history what can
that teach them knowing going back to
1895 or or maybe even a few years before
then to to know that the sentiment of
the the era what can that show them why
should they know more about the whole
history of how film began well I think
it helps you sort of see yourself
as people always been somebody
struggling and attempting to find a way
through a puzzling problem and it helps
you see that others have been there to
that you're not the first you're not the
first one to get up in the middle of
night and say oh my god what have I done
what isn't that beautiful others have
had exactly the same thought and
amazingly the others who thought that
often have turned out to be famous great
you know Giants but when they were doing
it they didn't know what they were doing
and I think it can be very liberating in
an odd way to come to understand how
much struggle there was for the first
people to do this kind of stuff it kind
of gives you courage your site is called
film charge and I got to tell you that
it is really profoundly encouraging to
sit there and just think about
moviemaking from the point of view other
people are doing it from the first time
and attempting to figure out well how do
i put sounds on top of moving image and
not confuse people or how do I chop up a
scene so that I increase its excitement
and energy in action because no one's
done this before so that's what I think
you can get out of it it can give you
sort of you cannonbolt in you because it
realizes that all artists are really
struggling with the same thing it's
always everybody's always at the
frontier no matter where you are it's
always the newest thing there's always
some kind of technology that people are
messing with and don't quite understand
and so that's what I think you can learn
it can in a weird way makes you not
afraid that's what i want to thank Bob
the interview today is taking place in
2015 and I'm wondering in your studies
of film history has the current
landscape of film lost the art of
storytelling and if so how I kind of
feel alone that movies have bifurcated
and gone in two directions certainly be
time productions have gotten way more
interested in crashes and blood spurt in
the end you know phantasmagoria of all
sorts of that don't engage at least some
audiences as all movies did and so I
would have to say if I can judge from my
own viewing habits my own interests that
yeah I do think that movies have gone
someplace else I find myself gravitating
towards watching Barbara Stanwyck on the
screen or watching tender mercies or
watching local hero or films that are
kind of humanely engaging but these have
become yeah you know minority film so
they are special films that's the kind
of value I think of the independent
cinema because corporate world so far as
I can understand not being in it the
corporate world has gone into the
entertainment business and the
entertainment business seems mainly like
the amusement park business to me and so
there's lots of thrills and chills but
as I kind of human experience which I
feel we really want from movies we don't
get it too much or at least I don't get
it too much I go to a movie like you
know oh jeez some it's man or something
you know and doesn't do anything for me
I just watch that stuff and there's one
crash after another one transformation
after another this is the heart for me
but when David Lynch sends that old
geezer on a you know on a lawnmower up
to visit brother in Northern USA I find
that moving and beautiful and so I do
feel there is a kind of movie which is
still being made which is telling
stories and involved with human struggle
but i must say that we have gotten away
from that
pretty commonly maybe it has to do with
the zeitgeist of the time I do feel
we're sort of more dark and concerned
that 911 changed us as a culture as a
country and its people in a very real
way none of us talk about it very much
and none of us can sort of articulated
to none of us recognize that others are
feeling the same way but I must say I
feel my own life he's got two parts and
there's before nine eleven and after
nine eleven and I do think that's to
some extent reflected in the movies
before and after after that time
although that connection is not
necessarily perfect and and direct but
lord knows I just find myself on
probably people from the 60s like me in
general going to the movies per se less
often than I used to watch Netflix or
watch TV but big budget production films
I rarely find myself going to because I
want something else I got a movie like
lives of others strike me as beautiful
wonderful film and it did win an Academy
Award but it's a typical of what we're
doing right now so I do think that
things have changed and I hope that we
can change them around again one way I
think we can change them around again
that we are change them around is that
all these other little alternative you
know venues for movies are making it
possible for people to do that kind of
thing in my book I wrote a little bit
and then there when I'm touching a
documentary about charlie bit me that
little clip on YouTube which I don't
know if you ever seen it but there's a
little boy and his brother sitting on a
couch in England and the one kid says
the other charlie bit me and ouch it
hurts and you think to yourself what the
heck
this you know charlie bit me when I
wrote the book or when the book came out
was about a year and a half ago when the
book came out there had been 480 million
hits there are now eight hundred and
twenty million hits obviously that
little exchange of two little children
sitting on sofa speaks to people in some
fundamental way that people want and
they're not necessarily getting in
big-time movies so I do think that
YouTube and Vimeo and all these other
venues we have for releasing films is
one way that we can get back to the kind
of stuff because you can do films more
cheaply and you can do more intimately
and so I'm hoping that that kind of
movie making will experience Renaissance
but lord knows the other kind of stuff
is in control right now what are the
average ages of your students your
professor yes I'm a professor a my
students are from what 18 to 22 mainly
okay oh and they've grown up in this
contemporary world and on often I'm just
astounded I'm just astounded at what
they're unfamiliar with you know I had
the one wonderful student the other day
we were talking about great films and
great performances and so on and I said
something about Marlon Brando and made
some comment about his performance and
he said yeah I'd like to talk about but
who's Marlon Brando and you know he said
yourself with my goodness we really have
lost some connection with our own
heritage and that's one of the wonderful
things you can do while studying film
history to you can bring that a little
bit back so they're 18 to 22 and they're
living in a world which is entirely post
9-11 and I think they're more fretful
and anxious than students here for
because of these people are more fretful
unanxious than we were and I guess
movies reflecting that going back to the
60s though the timing
change we're in the 50s everyone was a
good student and they obeyed their
parents and then i'm not sure what point
things started to unravel i think it was
Vietnam right that kind of set things
off and Kent State or now when did this
hall it was I can tell you the day
usually November was at number 20 second
1963 Jack Kennedy got shot and when Jack
Kennedy got shot the world changed it's
just like 911 was the same thing people
suddenly felt that the world in which we
had grown up in was totally transformed
that a new level of danger and
untrustworthiness he had arrived and I
would say that the assassination Jack
Kennedy was the 60s sixties really got
rolling few years later in 66 and 67
before that it was still more the 50s
but it was very turbulent time in a very
exciting time and we all thought that
we're going to transform the world and
to some extent we did but maybe the
world transformed us right so there was
the civil rights movement sexual
revolution is what is different today
because today's are there's mistrust
over the government there's the fear of
people reading our emails there's the
banks that many children you know
witness their parents homes being
foreclosed on what do you think the
difference is now it's hard to say
because in many ways there are
similarities it just feels some life
there's an underlying acceptance and
complacency even despite all those
protests that's different than the 60s
in the 60s it's felt a little realer in
the 60s it felt a little more dangerous
I happen to have had some experience for
just like a week or so as an exchange
student in a southern college and just
being in that environment for me and
northern kid
was really incredible sort of experience
so I'm not really a sociologist I can't
really explain why they are same and
what I different but my goodness that
was a profoundly transformative moment
and this one for all its troubles
doesn't quite feel the same way to me
Bob before we were rolling you told me
quickly that you had an experience where
a woman a stranger total stranger came
up to you right after nine eleven in a
parking lot I had gone to vote that
morning we had a local election i went
into the firehouse I passed the
fireman's TV screen and there was this
image of the World Trade Center and a
plane going into it and we all gate I
went home and called my wife and went to
a store I was in the parking lot of a
store and a woman came up to me a total
stranger and said that's it our lives
will never be the same utterly different
now and she walked away and the retro
said she was absolutely right it's true
we are a different culture now than we
were then we feel more vulnerable and
more aware of all the kinds of dangers
and bad things that could possibly
happen so I do think that's way you know
on us as a culture and certainly my
students seem more rum weary and
concerned than they were in the 60s also
in the 60s it was basically it was much
more prosperous time and getting more
Beckett jobs you didn't worry about
careers because those things were around
but now for young people coming out of
college it's a very serious concern and
you know it certainly is for people who
are in the arts it's particularly
serious I have many many students were
painters or sculpture as filmmakers
whatever and they love what they're
doing and then they save themselves so
how am I going to support myself how am
I going to make a life of this and many
of them struggle and many of them do
however somehow find a way may not be
what they thought but they do find some
way to do
that and but it takes courage and
strength would you say that's the number
one question you receive from all your
pre graduates what while they're getting
close to finishing up their last years
in college is that their biggest concern
they don't usually put it in words they
put in actions I'll tell you know I sit
there and say okay so what's the next
and they begin to sort of say well you
know I don't quite know I'm worried
about that I have to make some plans I'm
looking for this job and that job so
it's certainly on their minds in a way
that I think hasn't been on people's
minds for many many years that's one of
the darker sides of you know our
contemporary life and so how do you feel
that's reflected in the films that they
are making today that you're even the
little things you're seeing on YouTube
and in the the big studio films how do
you feel that that whole unknown because
there really isn't a set path anymore I
know back in even my time growing up in
the 80s you know if you did a certain
you know a B and C you felt that you
were going to get an outcome from it and
I think that all that is gone it's it's
not around so how do you feel as
reflected in there well I think some of
the bitter movies today express-times
and moving a fight club Fight Club seems
to me elderly unbelievably anxiety
provoking and full of angst and so I do
think that films that do succeed now due
to some extent and articulate that kind
of that kind of thing so they don't
actually say to you I'm scared I'm
worried about how am I going to support
myself but you see it you say
interactions because if yeah people are
who wants to talk about that kind of
stuff well you know I do how would I
don't want to make a video about it well
maybe but most people want to sort of
prevail over it mm-hmm and tough it out
sharp so it's not something when people
talk about very much but honestly you do
feel when you have been around for a
couple years at different times of
different tempers
this particular time is troubling one do
you feel that they think it's a weakness
on their part do you see maybe a
different level in let's say Millennials
more so than Generation Xers which is my
generation that maybe they don't want to
talk about anything that's considered
weak yes yes I do because one wants to
be powerful and once be strong wants to
be in control of one's life and there
are so many reasons is nowadays that
young people can't do that or have
difficulties sieving simple things um
find a way making a living finding a
mate other sort of level of
disaffiliation of sense your loneliness
that I find my students is really quite
alarming I just wish that more of them
could sort of live happily with friends
and find a kind of meaningful way for
themselves but it's harder now it's
simply it simply has gotten harder i'm
reminded of those horrible days you know
after world war two when they Italian
neo-realist were making movies and they
were making movies about people
struggling on the street and attempting
to sort of make some sense of their
lives after the world world world world
was over and they couldn't get film and
they could find jobs Italy was basically
bankrupt so those kinds of things are to
some extent reflected in the world in
general now Bob your book is make film
history yes right you said it came out
about a year and a half ago yes so which
chapter from your book is the most
important in your opinion and why if you
had to choose I know their first among
equals or but but what if you had to
choose one chapter that you feel is
really the essence of the book and what
any 25-year old if they could spend one
hour reading something put their phone
down for one moment what chapter do you
think would be the most vital in your
book of life
oh gosh that is a really hard hard
question and I guess I might be the one
where I just explained what classical
cutting is because it's a fundamental
sort of tool of everything we're done
with DW Griffith and his discovery of
classically cutting the scene because
that's the basic vocabulary of
filmmaking in establishing shot detail
shot close-up get out of it of this way
of organizing things I guess that that
would be the most important one if you
only could read one but there's so many
of them that seemed to me seemed to be
crucial on chapter on jean loaded are
and breathless i think is extremely
worthwhile because it enables you to see
the connection between somebody's
personality and their way of making a
movie you know in that chapter that the
book is a kind of a hybrid and that's
what sort of unusual about it there's
the book and there's also the web page
and so in the book you read the
description like books described and
then you go to the web page and their
various kind of resources with sing and
dance but finally you get some film
footage to work with and when you work
with the footage in many cases you're
working with clips from classic movies
or else in this particular case the one
from breathless we shot some footage of
our own to emulate a scene from
breathless and you know you begin to
sort of see what the effect of jump
cutting or not jump cutting the scene is
so I'd say it's really hard for me to
pick any one single chapter but I think
the really crucial thing to do is to
read the book and then mess with the
exercises whatever your level of
filmmaking skill is because the point of
my book which makes it different than
other books is that I'm going at this
from the point of view of a creative
person you know my idea in writing this
book was that I wasn't going to simply
dryly tell this happened that happened
and that happened that happened and so
on but I'm inviting people to sort of
imagine themselves in the middle of the
creative universe and see if they can't
discover what they would do given the
same kind of problem and solve it for
the first time gaddar in breathless I
started jump cutting because he had a
practical problem the movie was too long
I was going to do and so he simply said
hey let's just cut and that's what they
did and that sheer sort of necessity
created a whole feel and Gestalt for the
film so while it's hard for me to pick
out any single chapter I would say the
crucial thing to do is to go to the
webpage and win it with the book and
that's different than most film history
books up to this point most of the film
history books they're wonderful and
their area diet and their learning and
their broad and their deep but what they
are is connected to the experience of
making movies yourself my book is sort
of for people who would like to think
that they have within it themselves to
make a movie or through things like a
filmmaker at least understand what
filmmakers are thinking and so that's
the crucial thing it's not that any
particular chapter is crucial it's that
joining the book and the exercises in
the webpage that's the important thing
when you show clips in your classes of
classic films which resonate most with
today's generation the Millennials like
when you show them which which are the
ones they have the most questions about
or they are that are most polarizing to
them you know what's really interesting
the things that really speak to them or
the things which have always spoken to
people that in that respect I don't
think there's that many differences
between Millennials I showed for example
in more Bergman's wild strawberries few
weeks ago and they were blown away they
loved it they were so enthralled by that
film and the revelation at the end of
that movie when the old man lies in bed
and for the first time in that film sees
together his father and mother by the
reflecting pool at the end of the film
and you have this kind of Yogi and
vision of wholeness and completeness and
so on I don't care they're 18 19
whatever it was that spoke to them so i
would say that things that speak to
people today are the things that have
always spoken to them they are moments
which healing human emotions and a kind
of mythic truth all the razzmatazz in
the world finally doesn't speak to
people as deeply as moments and film
which are genuinely human revealing some
human person working through something
that is what still speaks to my film
students when you talk about temperament
of the filmmaker and I know Ingmar
Bergman has been you know he's he fought
sand demons of his own he was very
complex man but also very deep I believe
in so it's reflected in his films do you
talk about the filmmakers and they're
either the light films and their light
to enter absolutely and there's one
thing the Birdman said which I always
tell my film students because it seems
to me the heart of the film making
business and the heart of movies all
together and it's all about if you're
Birdman points out that when you watch a
two hour movie you're actually watching
a much shorter film because what's going
on is that since the image is
intermittent light dark light dark light
dark light dark um there are in essence
two projectors always at work because
the mechanical one or the digital one
and then there's this one right here
behind your pineal gland and you are
co-creating the film that you're
watching and it's kind of inherent in
nature of movies themselves so um
Bergman's sort of movies Express I think
that understanding that there's
something mythic and deep about any
movie but particularly is so that's why
I personally feel the Bergman fantastic
and honestly it's the great the great
guys in Fellini
workman must soon still love that and
what thrills me is that I show them a
movie like La Strada and they never
heard of it never seen it and still love
it but can you recommend the five or ten
top films someone should see to get a
great feel of the evolution of
filmmaking suppose they had a weekend
and they said I'm going to sit down and
watch ten films that Professor curse has
recommended what are they well I
certainly would like you to watch some
George as magical movies like Cinderella
or any of the sort of trip to the moon
trip to the moon will be fabulous
introduction on to the magical side of
filmmaking I'd like you to watch some
kind of classic documentary the nuclear
North would be good for the great white
light would be good from the 20s films
which attempt to look realistically and
honestly at the world even though he
always fail so I want you to do those
two things I'd love you to watch
something like them Shelby goes that I
let alone to see what French poetic
realism was like I love you to watch one
of the Italian neo-realist movies
Bicycle Thief I'd like you to watch
something with the new wave Truffaut
then I'd like you to watch after that
maybe you know something like Apocalypse
Now and moving on you know maybe even
being john malkovich and i think in that
kind of trip you would have seen movie
history play out pretty richly I suppose
there could have been some detours there
when we in 1927 1928 when we had that
fantastic sort of junction of silence
and sound a wonderful silent film which
shows what happened to silent movies
when they turned in the talkies is a
movie from lonesome by Paul viejos which
its prime
early silent movie it's about a boy and
girl young man and one woman who run off
to Coney Island where I spent many hours
because my grandpa had a store in Coney
Island and it's a beautiful sword boy
meets girl boy loses girl silent movie
but in the middle of it suddenly because
is 1928 they decided they had to shoot
some sound scenes and their clunky their
ridiculous the preposterous it's like
you know somebody's grading a finger
over blackboard and it just demonstrates
if you won't understand why it was that
filmmakers said oh I don't want to go to
sound it was that kind of thing so that
that range of movies I think would be
would be a wonderful introduction to
just what happened in movie history Bob
as you watched us adjust our camera i'm
curious well DIY filmmaking become the
end of Hollywood Oh certainly will move
it somewhere else than where it seems to
want to go and I know it would be the
end of Hollywood I think it'll be a new
kind of movie on a personal movie and
much to be valued I think that George
yourself do it your own camera do it on
an iPhone do it on wherever you can
certainly is going to change then you
know the nature of movies under George
Lucas was saying recently that he's
dismayed at the nature of Hollywood
today and it's made its a kind of
big-budget some kind of razzmatazz which
is not personal I think that
do-it-yourself movies are inherently
more personal and so whether it knots
the end of Hollywood or a new beginning
it certainly will change things that's
that's really all I could say about when
you say that you know we we watch movies
to see the human experience and feel
things and now we've gone away from now
we have social media which seems like it
would be part of the human experience
with it's actually not
we're representing ourselves online in a
certain way that we want everyone to see
us as so that's not real but do you feel
that because reality has become so
distorted that people want to make their
own films that get back to that in terms
of the reality TV is not that it's I
think there's a real hunger no these
foot to return to those kinds of things
and if you can't do it in a big-budget
film which seems harder and harder to do
so far as I can see because someone
would get involved with huge budgets you
have to worry about mass audiences and
you have to worry about what will play
in Bombay as well as what a play in
Queens so I do think that you know
independent films are returning us to
that experimental mode we're in way back
in 1895 that in a weird way 2015 is not
so different from 1895 because nowadays
you have all these people trying out new
things trying new ways new machines near
devices so I'm optimistic what it's
going to do the Hollywood exactly you
know I I couldn't really say I think
that however something good will come
out of all the stuff any thoughts on the
future of filmmaking for the next 5 10
15 years well I see it some much more
interactive than it ever was before and
once were you to be than ever was before
and much more like people sitting around
the fire you know in the darkness
telling stories to another than it was
before become less professional are more
authentic or real I guess I really am a
kind of independent film guy the movies
I really love our movies that did at one
time or another attempt to sort of their
personal witness to the world little
movable little fugitive other than if
you were sought 1952 Mars angle goes out
on the beach in Coney Island
and doesn't movie about a little boy who
thinks he shot his brother horse is not
true and so he spends a weekend on the
beach in Coney Island and Morris angles
out there with a handmade camera um with
the silent camera was they dubbed
finally and it's a living authentic film
so I'm hoping that we'll move in that
direction whether or not happens I don't
know but I think it might not be welcome
and if it does it just as the fear you
spoke of in 1895 you're telling me I've
manager froze on camera off that about
the train coming toward the audience and
people never seeing something like this
and thought it was real what fears do
you see people have now about this new
media and maybe they're valid maybe it's
just fear of change well I think
everybody feels things are getting out
of control and that it's very difficult
to figure your way through this thicket
of new media and new opportunities new
opportunities are also sort of confusing
because the career paths are not as
simple and obvious as they were before
so that's you know that's frightening I
think two people but there's enormous
possibility i think we'll get through
this stuff i think it'll work i'm
optimistic about it but for the moment
we're just running around trying to fit
around our way how can one tell that a
filmmaker is before their time in the
current day and not 20 years from now
realizing huh and they were a pioneer oh
I guess there before their time if
people simply don't respond if they
simply don't emotionally get what the
heck is is going on in this film um I've
it's difficult question though how can
we tell whether they're before their
time tell me some more yeah is it maybe
I'm
apologies if I'm not explaining it
correctly I guess there's been so many
people that were shunned during their
time from their peers whether it's van
Gogh or certain people that once they
passed away and years it you know had
gone by then people realized how you
know much of a sort of a genius they
were and I'm just wondering if there are
any sort of telltale signs but maybe
that's it then just people that don't
sort of fit the mold they don't fit in
there not really regarded you know
there's that that biblical saying sort
of no man's a prophet in his own land
type of thing and maybe that's it so
maybe someone that's heralded as sort of
a hero now maybe wouldn't be into it
it's art you know it's very hard to say
I I would say that filmmaker from the
past like this Paul lejos made one movie
a lonesome beautiful beautiful fabulous
film it never connected it languished
for years it's been recently
rediscovered and people can now see it
for the wonderful mythic film it was but
it didn't connect it maybe it wasn't
marketed right maybe he simply did not
know to bring it to but it's I think at
the moment it's kind of hard to tell
time tells all and that's one of those
values of history that you can look back
and see things that seem valuable art
and things that seemed unvalued are
that's the one of the benefits of
thinking historically speaking of which
what films of each era do you think
resonated the most if we go back a
hundred years so each decade let's say
which films resonated the most with that
time amongst audiences and why do you
think that would be maybe pick five or
so well suddenly the birth of the nation
was incredibly a sort of big in 1915
most of us kind of horrible tell us now
because the racial attitude in that film
is really reprehensible but for people
in 1915 who were looking
back at the civil war that was the 50th
year anniversary of the Civil War I
guess that film constellated their
feelings about that war and their
country and so that was really a a
monumental a monumental film I don't
know Citizen Kane not really i don't
think that really did too much a movie
like Stella Dallas with Barbara Stanwyck
I think resonated powerfully because he
in her performance of the kind of love
and mother who was nevertheless
frustrated i think spoke to so many
particularly women at that particular
time i think that really resonated a
film like gosh High Noon 1952 resonated
fantastically powerfully because at that
period when people were involved with
the McCarthy era and you know attempting
to understand who would stand by you and
who wouldn't I think that film resonated
you know fantastically ah you know
breathless my goodness in 1960s for the
first time most of us saw breathless
that resonated enormously we couldn't
figure out why because we thought god
this guy doesn't even know him in
filmmaking I mean is that matching shots
right is Miss Cod's here but somehow or
other it had the verb and feeling it had
the kind of result of its age and so
those kinds of movies it seems to me
powerfully resonate and I wouldn't
necessarily continue to resonate their
movies that were real big in their day
that don't mean too much anymore so they
were a hit then but then they fizzled
yeah because I i think that they spoke
the feelings of their time and that's
different than having a truly great
classic film like a Birdman or a Fellini
or winter light which are about eternal
spiritual things
about method quests and for some reason
you know talk to people forever 70s 80s
90s anything of each decade that maybe
spoke that's a driver I think taxi
driver really resonated why um what
about the actor I think about that
character when Robert Niro looks in the
mirror and says you talkin to me he's
nothing to me because there's no one
else here you're talking to me I think
that kind of potentiate it out the
spirit of it at that time I think that
was incredibly sort of powerful film
that that's a kind of movie I think
Fight Club certainly did for the same
kind of reason because it's full of
angst and confusion and conflict and
vigor and energy so I think movies that
do speech out of their particular moment
our movies that you know resonate for
their time 80s what's in five clubs 90s
right yeah that's why 80s what would we
think oh jeez hmm you big haha yeah all
Rome you know Forrest Gump yeah
horoscope but certainly slimey's um that
that kind of film um III think movies
that do however have some kind of mythic
heart or our movies which stay today's
movie business compared to let's say 50
years ago 60 years ago let me compare it
to something a little earlier which is
the studio system in nineteen late 20s
and early 30s um when people had seven
year contracts and vast numbers of
people were employed and there was a
kind of trade identity and a kind of
security about the business that was in
many ways beneficial and which kind of
sustained American filmmaking was what
made American
different than European films because
the European films even back then we're
more organized the way we do it now pick
up a company you get some people
together to find the script you find a
producer you put it together to do it
once and it's all over that's that was
basically prevailing European model for
many years you know the studio system I
sense not having been there but for what
I hear about it was a big family and
people felt happy and secure working for
it and took the kind of pride and doing
a kind of workmen like job which is a
different sort of head remember running
into a wonderful old director years ago
and I said to him what's your greatest
sense of accomplishment he said I always
brought my movies in on time and I
always my movies always made money and
it was great and that was my
satisfaction there's no talk and that
about heart or soul or character I think
so is a different kind of perspective in
a more industrially oriented of you know
sustaining environment that's different
now when we meet people and pick up
groups and shoot whatever we can shoot
so it's some really much more
fragmentary kind of life I think and it
was for filmmakers back in the golden
days of the studio and I guess they felt
um sustained by it was hard work and
hours and so on but there was a kind of
secure identity that I think they had
that we often don't anymore and then
things changed and how well when the
city has broke up in the 50s that was a
really sort of crucial break point for
movie history you know when stars
instead of producers were sort of in
control and people running their own
contracts and financing their own movies
for better or worse things changed and
when studios lost their distribution
arms and
their exhibit in theaters things changed
and better worse it's different great
things happens but it's different aside
from your book where can someone else
discover history of film a lot of the
textbooks around you know David
bordelles textbook is great Jannetty
excellent watch old movies I find that
you know watching old films on netflix a
great experience don't worry about what
they have you looking at I feel like
flow Barre said about novels that how
wise one would be if one knew only well
five or six novels I think that if you
find an old movie that you like and it
speaks to you you should watch it a
hundred times I think that is the
greatest education about film history
there is I must have seen the third man
by Sir carol reed hundred times and i
think that that has taught me more about
pacing and film lighting
characterization writing and so on than
any kind of broad survey so i personally
feel that there are textbooks around and
you certainly can use them but the best
thing i think you can do is just watch
old movies and when you find one that
really speaks to you by watch it forever
and it'll deeply need your appreciation
of where movies came from so when
someone watches a film more than once
what starts to happen that same film
let's suppose they've seen it twice now
now they're seeing beyond certain things
you begin to see more and you begin to
see how the film is constructed and you
begin to sort of appreciate all the
little things that all the perhaps
people did when you're watching for
example the third man and you notice
that when the woman walks into the room
between two other men and she stands
exactly in front of a portrait of a
woman behind her and then they cut you
realize that the editor is himself and
for
sizing the theme of the film which is
this kind of vagrant identity which is
floating around this film's mysterious
person who is neither live nor dead and
you begin to sort of get it more you see
it more if it's a well made movie a
great movie is a movie that repays that
kind of attention a lousy movie you
watch it once or twice and you're done
yes there's nothing more to it but
really good films I think bear that kind
of attention on so you just begin to see
what everybody has done to make that
film rich and full and that's what makes
a great movie